now I feel like I should begin with the
biggest news of the century that nobody
else is covering for some reason
scientists recently discovered a strange
elongated large tube that was that it
was careening through the solar system
apparently came from another solar
system and then was was you know going
around and then it left the solar system
okay and they dubbed it they called this
thing Oh mwah mwah Oh mwah mwah is what
they called it which means weird space
tube in Hawaiian I don't know if that's
really what it means but anyway the
thing is I said it came from another
solar system ended up in ours left and
now researchers at Harvard Smithsonian
Center for Astrophysics just wrote a
paper theorizing you guessed it that
this may have been aliens who came to
this solar system on a reconnaissance
mission and will return to enslave
mankind no they didn't they didn't
extrapolate it all the way there but
they did say it could be there could be
aliens behind this this tube thing so I
mean it just seems kind of silly for us
to be sitting around worried about
elections when we're about to be
enslaved by these malevolent super
aliens like and were what it's just it
doesn't make any sense why aren't more
people talking about this anyway as we
as I guess as we await our fate and we
await the arrival of the aliens which is
which is by the way not something is is
not a result that I would find
particularly displeasing I'm kind of
looking forward to it honestly but as we
wait for that I do have a couple things
I want to say about about a voting day
the first thing is you know today on
voting day people are encouraged really
more than encouraged they are they are
cajoled harassed emotionally blackmailed
Bry
threatened into voting and many people
will respond to that and they'll go out
and vote and and they have already gone
to vote many people and they'll announce
it proudly on the internet and say hey I
voted the idea is that voting is some
kind of civic duty and if you vote you
fulfilled that Duty which of course
means we know in modern society that
anytime you do something you're supposed
to do the first thing you do is you tell
everybody about it
that's why the internet exists now I
agree that voting is a civic duty but I
just think we should clarify because it
is not clarified enough that it is a
secondary civic duty it is it is maybe I
should say a a contingent duty it is a
duty that depends first on fulfilling
another responsibility a primary
responsibility and that responsibility
is to be knowledgeable and informed and
engaged as a citizen and as I've said
many times this is my problem with the
get-out-the-vote campaigns where we're
told to you know go vote just vote vote
vote vote just go vote go vote that's
all but nobody ever mentions oh you know
what by the way maybe you want to learn
a couple things about our country and
about our system of government maybe you
should know like for instance what the
branches of government are and you
should have a basic fundamental idea of
how they operates so that when you vote
for someone you know not only should you
know who they are but you should know
what job you're putting them in and what
it is that they're going to be doing
like these are things you should know
before you go vote but the message that
we we send is that basically knowledge
is irrelevant and an information is
irrelevant
you know it doesn't matter how much
knowledge you have how much information
you you know that's simply not true you
not
have a duty to vote or I should say you
only have a duty to vote if you have
fulfilled the duty of being an engaged
informed contributing member of society
if you haven't done that yet if you have
not gotten past first base yet you
haven't rounded first that's first base
then you can't then then you can't go on
to the next base if you haven't bothered
to inform yourself then I think voting
is actually not only not a duty for you
but I'd say it's an act of supreme
recklessness and selfishness because you
are in that case inflicting your
obliviousness on the rest of us you're
making a decision based on nothing you
know so we'd like to say that well
voting is a really important decision
and so did the most important decision
you'll ever make which of course it
isn't but if it's an important decision
then obviously it should be a decision
that you make based on something if
you're not making it based on anything
then you shouldn't be making it at all
you'd be making a mockery of the system
abusing it in that case I think the
problem in America one of the problems
anyway among many is that many people
approach voting in the same way that
they approach like the game of pool you
know if you've ever played pool against
someone who doesn't know what they're
doing and and so what they do is that
they'll they know if their stripes are
solids and so they just kind of wind up
with the pool cue and and smack the
white ball in the general vicinity of
the assigned ball and I have found that
very often just like with fantasy
football the the person in the fantasy
football doesn't know what they're doing
always wins
and so it's the same thing with pool
like those people for whatever reason
often are very successful but in pool
you know that's that's a fine way to go
about it they just sort of hit and pray
method of like I don't know what I'm
doing I'm just I'm just putting the ball
in that direction but I think we should
approach voting with a bit more
knowledge and competency if you're not
informed if you're not
to cast a meaningful vote then your
patriotic responsibility is to stay home
and try again on the next go-round when
you have you know learned a thing or two
I know that sounds harsh but but it's
true and no one else will say it so that
means every time there's an election I
have to be the water size now for those
who are informed and prepared to cast a
meaningful vote maybe we should talk a
little bit about what's at stake here
what happens if Democrats take the house
or the Senate and they probably won't
take the Senate i I've learned not to
make any predictions when it comes to
politics so I'm not gonna I you know I I
have no idea what's gonna happen but if
they make gains and take control of
either the House or Senate what what
happens then well I think a few things
happen now that we should keep this or
mine first thing that happens with
Democrats and control of of let's say
the house is is the first thing that
happens is a lot of nothing gridlock we
know that basically nothing substantial
will get done with Democrats in it's
already hard enough to get anything fast
an shal done with get done with just
Republicans but but with Democrats in
then we really know that that's it and
this is where we are now with politics
in America and it really has not always
been this way I think we think we take
it for granted that well you know this
is all it always has been politics has
always been this sort of
rough-and-tumble
sport and there's always been this
division and yeah that's all true but
there did used to be a time when the
parties could agree at least on some
things but but that's not really the
case anymore the Democrats will simply
obstruct and interfere with anything
that Trump and the Republicans try to do
so it will be total dysfunction that
that's what politics has become now it's
just become whatever party is not in
power they just disagree with whatever
the the empower parties is trying to do
so that's the first thing I'll happen
that's the first thing we can look
forward to if Democrats get in there the
second thing is it will be presented as
a historic indictment of Trump's
presidency no matter no matter how silly
that characterization may be that
so what the media is gonna do now
granted if the Democrats did take the
house and the Senate then yes it would
be not at a historic indictment but
quite an indictment anyway but there'd
be nothing especially remarkable about
Republicans losing just the house you
know I don't think it would be a really
significant statement about Trump or
about his agenda that's how the media
will present it but it would just if
that's the case it'll just be kind of
how these midterms usually go but the
third thing and this is the most
important I think and I touched on it
yesterday a Democrat victory will reward
and this is the worst thing about it it
will reward their deceit they're
deceitful immoral obstructionist tactics
will be remor reward now I'm under no
illusion that if they're defeated it may
cause them to rethink their their whole
way of approaching things and they'll
have a come-to-jesus moment and you know
they'll reform themselves I don't
that's not gonna happen but at least it
would be a rebuke it would be a
righteous rebuke a victory of any sort
for the Democrats allows their evil to
prevail and so I think that's reason
enough to as they themselves might say
resist
I think that's reason enough to resist
them because they need to be they cannot
be rewarded for the way that they have
carried on especially over the last two
years and especially in the last couple
of months now with all that said let me
also just mention one other thing and I
think it's crucial and I know this might
sound like contradictory but I don't
think it is this election is very
important and in a sense it really is
the most important in our lifetime they
say that every election is the most
important in our lifetime and in a sense
that's true because the election that we
have now is the most recent and
therefore it is you know the most
pressing and will and will have the
greatest impact on our lives because it
just so happens to be the most recent
one and though I do hope that Democrats
are rebuked and resisted as they need to
be I do also think that as we vote
we need to keep in mind that our entire
lives and our well-being and our
happiness is not hinged on the results
of an election for the most part our
lives the significant part of our lives
anyway the most important parts are not
noticeably affected by political
outcomes for most people now that isn't
to say that we shouldn't vote or that
voting doesn't matter I'm just trying to
caution against this attitude that this
belief that politicians hold in their
hands the key to our very existence to
our satisfaction with life to our joy
and fulfillment and they can they can
end civilization as we know it they can
end our happiness and and and ever they
can make life a barren nihilistic
wasteland of meaninglessness if you know
that they have the ability to do that
and they don't
now those egoists they would certainly
like for us to see it that way
they they they they play this up because
they want you to think that they have
that kind of control over your life
but they really don't and I think we've
lost this perspective over time it's
like we were we are incapable of having
any kind of perspective so even what I'm
saying right now I know they're gonna
people be people who say well how could
you say that you're discouraging people
from voting I'm not discouraging anyone
I'm just saying it's possible to
encourage someone to do something
without claiming that it's the most
important thing in the world that if it
goes wrong their life will be over you
know it is possible to have some little
bit of perspective on these things or
yes it's super important but it's not
you know 95 percent of your life will go
on as normal no matter what party is in
control now the five percent that is
affected that's important that's five
percent of a life it's important portion
but the fact remains that I just I want
to get rid of this notion that I think
is really just unamerican
and and harmful this notion that
politicians have
much control over us and you saw this
with I mean look at the way Democrats
reacted when Trump was was elected they
were and still are just utterly
traumatized falling to their knees in a
street screaming meanwhile meanwhile
although various policies have been put
through that they disagree with and and
all of that their lives have gone on as
normal
their life has been basically it for
them their lives have been almost
exactly what their lives would have been
had the election gone their way there's
very little difference actually
substantively because as you go about
your you know you wake up you know you
you have your kids you have your spouse
and maybe you you go to work you come
back to your family I would hope that
most of your joy and meaning in life is
derived from from that from your from
your family from your faith from these
things that you still have no matter who
is in office so I just want to keep that
in mind as well all right so much for
the election all we can do now is is
after we have voted all we can do now is
hope and and pray I want to go back to a
topic we covered yesterday I mentioned
this story of Marsden Riley who's the
high school teacher in California
arrested for punching a student and the
student was was asked to leave the
classroom he refused that he got in the
teacher's face began threatening him
cussing him out hurling racial slurs
he threw a basketball at the teacher at
Riley finally Riley had enough punched
the student then a fight broke out and
now Riley is being charged with child
abuse
now I said that I have sympathy for the
teacher III have no sympathy for the
punk kid whatsoever I'm sorry I just
don't I understand as I said yesterday
that I understand that the school can't
officially condone punching students but
I hope
that they just suspend Riley with pay
for a week or something like that then
send them back to work while expelling
the students so I hope they come down
much harder on the student than they do
on the teacher and my reason for that is
twofold number one Riley's a human being
and humans can reach a breaking point
especially when they're abused and
harassed all the time by punks like this
kid which apparently is the case with
with Riley and I and I'm guessing is
probably the case with a lot of teachers
at the school I know we're kind of used
to we say well that's just what it means
to be a teacher yeah that may be that is
what it means to be a teacher these days
but it shouldn't be that way that's not
how it's supposed to be that's that's
not normal it's that's not how schools
are in many other countries where it's
just like yeah well the kids are totally
out of control I've no respect at all
that complete delinquents they act like
animals you know it's just how it is you
just have to deal with that do you ever
think that maybe our attitude towards it
is why it is that way
I'm schools were not like that 50 years
ago and I know there are many reasons
for that we could talk about but I'm
just saying schools have not always yes
there's always been delinquent kids
there's always been behavior problems it
hasn't always been like this it just
hasn't but the second thing is the point
I make it made is I think it would be a
terrible message to fire this teacher
the the message would be that students
can treat teachers however they want and
if the teacher defends himself or reacts
in a human way he'll be fired his life
will be over
that's essentially I mean this is his
career anyway let's say well we'll be
over so the delinquent student wins
twice over he wins by harassing the
teacher and then he wins by seeing the
teacher's life destroyed because he was
able to provoke this human reaction and
I just think that's untenable students
should understand that if they behave
this way and a teacher responds they the
student will not win I think that's
gotta be the message from the school to
a student like this you are not going to
win when you act this way
sorry actually not sorry you're just not
gonna win the student should know that
if I act like this and that is just way
over the top in someone's face screaming
racial slurs look throwing things you
know if I act that way and I'm able to
elicit a response I'm able to provoke
the teaser and the smacking me in the
face
guess what's gonna happen yeah that
teachers gonna get a slap on the wrist
and I'm gonna get expelled and I think
that's the message that that student
should well as I said yesterday what is
the downside to students knowing that I
can think of many downsides to the
opposite scenario where they know that
they can do whatever they want there
will be no immediate consequences and if
they are able to provoke an immediate
consequence in the form of a smack to
the face of something like that then the
teacher is the one who's gonna suffer
the harshest consequence I can think of
many problems with that scenario which
is the scenario that we have in almost
every school in the country right now
there are many problems we're looking at
the problems I don't see any problems
with the other way of doing it now and
as I said I think the kid deserved it
you know I just I just think he did I
think he needed it too now anyway kind
of kind of kind of shockingly I was you
know I was contacted last night kind of
late last night I was contacted by the
organizers of an event that I'm supposed
to be speaking at soon and they
uninvited me from the event they told me
I'm not welcome anymore apparently
because of my opinion on this issue
which it's I have said so many things
that I think are way more controversial
than this but this was enough to get me
uninvited apparently my defense of the
teacher and my lack of sympathy for the
out-of-control delinquent was hurling
racial slurs and basketballs at him that
that was you know that's just
unacceptable apparently it kind of
strange considering many students at the
school are supporting teacher and his
fellow teachers are supporting him and
someone set up a
it will go fund me that raise like
$70,000 in a day so it seems like most
people like me are simply fed up with
this kind of behavior and they're
especially fed up with it being
tolerated from from from kids and they
just aren't going to cry any tears when
one of these delinquents gets punched in
the face I think that's the attitude of
most people so I and that's why I didn't
even think that what I said was all that
controversial it seemed like there was
wide agreement on the on the point and
and you know honestly I think some of
these kids this is a lesson they need to
learn and I and I think for their own
safety it's better that they learn it
like that then maybe through something
that's a bit more severe than a punch to
it to the face because you know this kid
if he doesn't learn now one of these
days he's going to run his mouth to the
wrong person in the wrong situation and
and the consequences of that are going
to be significantly worse than getting
punched in the face and so it really is
for their own safety these kids gotta
learn like you cannot act that way not
not everyone's gonna tolerate it and
people have different ways of not
tolerating these things and you need to
know that but you know I was uninvited
and and there were there were other
people not a majority but but but some
who expressed disapproval of my
unchristian position on this topic one
thing that I heard quite a bit is that
it's never okay to hit anyone right it's
never okay to hit and that's the refrain
that you often hear in this situation
well it's never okay to hits never okay
to use violence but is that true and why
is it true now look let's put this
particular incident aside for the moment
and just deal with that blanket
statement which is so
common these days in the case of a
teacher my argument was that the
teachers actions were understandable and
I'm sympathetic to it and in the long
run I think I'll even benefit the kid
who needed to be taught a lesson but I
didn't you know there's a difference
between saying that an action is
understandable and saying an action is
okay so we could debate about whether it
was okay in fact you know we have to say
officially it's not okay and that's what
the school has to say which is why you
know there has to be some minor
consequence but it is in my view
understandable but I don't want to deal
with whether it can be understandable
let's talk about the people that say
it's never okay well you know it's never
okay to respond to words with violence
or whatever where does that come from we
take it as this obvious self-evident
truth but why can you explain that why
is it not okay where are you getting
that idea from you're not getting it
from the Bible I'll tell you that much
now yeah Jesus did say turn the other
cheek he also used a whip against the
money changers in the temple and the
Bible is filled with examples of force
being used and sanctioned by God so it's
just not true that the Bible calls us to
be nonviolent at all times and and
honestly I can't believe that anyone who
thinks that way has actually opened the
book I mean just open it didn't read it
this is this is not a peacenik religion
that worrying i mean certainly not a
violent religion either I'm not saying
that but it's it is not a hippie
peacenik violence is never justified
religion it just simply isn't old or New
Testament there is very little
justification you can find theologically
for that point of view so where do they
get this idea now I have to assume that
the people who say it's always wrong to
hit someone they must agree that that
physical self-defense is
exception I have to assume that you
agree with that so but but are there
other situations where it could be okay
not just understandable but okay morally
to hit somebody
who has not hit first these days we say
no I think most of human society up
until recently we would all agree that
of course there are situations where it
could be okay but now we say no never
okay never okay um can you explain that
though without just restating the
premise well its violence
okay fine its violence so what so what's
your point why is it always worse why is
it always on justified can you explain
it without just restating it let's take
one hypothetical let's take a
hypothetical that isn't I mean it's not
people have encountered situations like
this is not totally out landed let's say
you're out with your wife and a man
comes up and doesn't physically cut your
wife or you but screams interface
harasses or calls her various sexually
demeaning names as the man as the
husband would it be completely not okay
completely wrong for you to respond to
this behavior by punching the man in the
face to defend your wife's honor and
your own and to teach this man a lesson
I think it would be I think in fact a
punch to the face all things being equal
B would be the most appropriate response
all things being equal my point is that
it seemed it just seems clear to me that
occasions can arise where it is
perfectly justified moral and just to
use physical force in the face of even
non-violent provocation that doesn't
mean that it's okay you just run around
punching everybody or that anytime
someone upsets you can punch them that's
not the point but there there you know
there are clearly situations where a
physical response is warranted and I
think we just live in this really weak
emasculated culture
we've got this idea that it's just no
never okay I mean that's the kind it's
like it's almost childish it's just you
you you you're getting this from from
from children's TV shows this idea I
mean if a man defended his wife in that
situation and we're to punch the guy in
the face lay him out on the ground
would you really go to him said yeah you
shouldn't have done that you should have
did well we should he excuse me sir
excuse me I really would but I really
would I would prefer if you would stop
harassing my wife sir please would you
please what if you wouldn't mind please
please sir please if you wouldn't mind
stop calling my wife those names sir
please I police are I'm asking you
nicely if I now I'm now I'm going to
write a formal request that you please
stop here you go here's my here's I've
written on sticky note please I think at
a certain point you know it at a certain
point a more let's say corporal method
it can be warranted so I just that that
blanket statement that people make I
think is is to me it's just absurd and
like I said it is not I'm sorry but it
actually is not a statement that is
clearly vindicated by Christian teaching
all right what else oh one more thing
yesterday people who watch the show you
can't see it if you're listening I've
seen on iTunes but people who watch the
show notice that there's a banjo I think
you can see it in the there's a banjo
right there behind me and people noticed
it in there some people were asking me
if I could even play it and maybe sing a
song or something well as for singing I
would never do that to you because my
singing voice sounds like the noises a
warthog makes when you boil it alive in
acid and yes I do know what that sounds
like
but as for playing the banjo I cannot do
that
I don't know how to play the banjo even
though I have that banjo right there and
I tell you this as a cautionary tale
okay let me just take a quick story here
I you see about about eight years ago
before we were married my then fiancee
now wife asked me what I want for my
birthday and I said you know jokingly
but I said that I'd really gotten into
bluegrass music recently which I had and
I'd like to learn the banjo well my wife
very thoughtfully went out and she
bought a banjo for my birthday and she
even you know she researched tried to
find the best banjo she could find and
she found a great banjo and she bought
she gave me so I got it on my birthday
so I'm so excited to play the banjo so
so that same week I went and I got some
banjo books and I downloaded some banjo
tutorials to learn how to play and I'm
telling you that I spent minute after
minute after minute trying to learn the
banjo but after many minutes I mean many
many minutes I'm talking forty-five even
fifty of them I realized that learning
the banjo was really hard and so I gave
up and now that that was eight years ago
that banjo now just sits there staring
at me and judgment every single day of
my life and my wife because she is a
woman never forgets anything ever and so
she has not forgotten about the banjo
and the banjo that I asked for and never
played and gave up on the very same day
that it was given to me so on occasion
she'll pull out that trump card and
she'll say oh yeah well you never
learned the banjo or every time she
gives me a gift now for eight years
every time she always say it like the
same thing well hopefully you use this
one unlike the banjo or anytime someone
comes over and they see the banjo and
then there's always that awkward cough
oh you know the banjo you know how to
play the banjo and then my wife well let
me tell you a story about the time I
bought him a banjo he never learned it
and she's right I have no response I
have been I didn't learn the Badger I
had been tempted over the years to learn
it just so that my wife couldn't use it
against me anymore but then I realized
that it
kind of weird to learn the banjo out of
spite the banjo is not a very spiteful
instrument unlike say the tuba or
something so the lesson here my only
point is the lesson here for men is
never ask your wife or the woman in your
life to get you an instrument as a gift
that you don't know how to play because
she will expect you to learn it and if
you don't you will suffer the curse of
the banjo which has been my life now and
the only way to put an end to the curse
is to learn it but as I said it is way
too hard all right
um we'll leave it there go go vote if
you haven't I mean vote if you are
informed and you know what you're doing
then go vote and I'll talk to you
tomorrow
Godspeed